[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le journal sur
tv 78 très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale nous sommes le lundi 17 mai voici
les titres à la veille de la période
estivale la spa organise son mois de
l'adoption jusqu'à la fin mai est
l'occasion de sensibiliser le public à
l'engagement que représente l'accueil
d'un animal évitez aussi les abandons
malheureusement nombreux chaque été
reportage refuge d'orgeval et invité
guillaume sanchez directeur général de
la spa
elle fête ses 10 ans à elancourt
l'association cynophiles de la police
municipale forme des maîtres chiens de
brigades de toute l'île de france mais
aussi d'eure-et-loir et d'indre et loire
et les formations se déroulent tous les
mardis à elancourt sur un terrain prêté
par la ville
et puis elle avait fermé en janvier 2020
faute de repreneur la librairie lettres
voisine a finalement ouvert un an après
avoir un le bretonneux toujours pas de
repreneur mais une solution a été
trouvée avec la commune une réouverture
dans d'autres locaux loués par la mairie
mais avant de développer ces titres est
la vaccination contre le coc vie 19
s'accélère au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
vaccinodromes ouvre des créneaux pour
les salariés des entreprises du bassin
de l'agglomération et ce quel que soit
leur âge des rendez-vous qui peuvent se
prendre en fin de journée de 17 heures à
18 heures ou lors de sessions nocturnes
le vendredi 250 créneaux sont réservés
par jour à ce titre pour ce faire des
sociétés doivent se rapprocher de
l'agglomération toutes les informations
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran est la
semaine dernière sur place la barre des
100000 vaccination a été franchie saint
quentin en yvelines qui compte dix sept
mille entreprises et 145 1000 salariés
sur son territoire le colis de 19 qui
connaît un recul sur le territoire
yvelinois deux jours avant la deuxième
étape du déconfinement qui interviendra
le 19 mai tous les indicateurs sont à la
baisse dans le département mais reste
sur un niveau très élevé le taux
d'incidence est repassé en dessous des
200 c'est le nombre de nouveaux
contaminée pour 100000 habitants le taux
de positivité aux tests et à 5,4 pour
cent
un 10,9 points sur une semaine la
tension hospitalière ce dessert
également un peu plus de 113 % des lits
de réanimation saute occupés sont
occupés en ile-de-france 436 patients
étaient hospitalisés hier dimanche dans
les yvelines 77 2 - en une semaine et
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
1774 personnes sont décédées du colis de
19 dans les hôpitaux évinois la
direction orgeval à présent où se tient
depuis le 6 mai lé mois de l'adoption au
refuge spa comme partout en france une
opération qui doit permettre de trouver
des familles est responsable pour les
chiens chats et nouveaux animaux de
compagnie avant d'en parler avec mon
invité un reportage de mickeal et demi
d'euros et d'eléonore synopsis on
recherche un petit chien adopté ce qu'on
vit dans un appartement une adoption
responsable c'est tout l'enjeu du mois
de l'adoption qui se déroule depuis le 6
et ce jusqu'au 23 mai au sein des
refuges spa cette opération remplacent
les traditionnelles portes ouvertes qui
ne peuvent pas se tenir cette année à
cause de la crise sanitaire
on redoute un pic d'abandons du au
probable départ en vacances des gens qui
n'ont pas pu partir l'année dernière
donc
on appréhende un petit peu ce moment là
c'est pourquoi voilà nous avons souhaité
proposer le mois de l'adoption à la
place des portes ouvertes
simon redoute aussi le fait que les gens
on reprenne le travail à temps plein
alors jeux valve une cinquantaine de
chiens une soixantaine de chats et
quelques nouveaux animaux de compagnie
les nac attendent de trouver une famille
toujours avec l'objectif de les faire
adopter de façon responsable
il faut se poser les questions savoir si
on souhaite plus avoir un chien un chat
ou un hack en fonction de notre mode de
vie
donc le type d'habitation les heures
d'absence qu'il y aura pour l'animal
s'il y a des enfants à venir par exemple
'cependant un engagement sur le long
terme qui doit être mûrement réfléchie
dans les yvelines les trois refuges spa
de plaisir r murray orgeval participe
donc évidemment à ce mois de l'adoption
qui doit permettre d'attirer plus de
monde et de montrer le savoir faire du
personnel de l'association
on espère effectivement que les gens
vont se déplacer en refuge après on
demande aussi aux adoptants de faire
confiance à nos équipes parce que mon
connaît bien nos animaux alors c'est
vrai que parfois une démarche d'adoption
peut prendre du temps avant de trouver
l'animal qui correspond à la famille
mais après la famille n'en sera que plus
heureux une fois qu'elle aura trouvé le
loulou qui lui correspond depuis janvier
2021 la spa d'orgeval a permis à 272
animaux chiens chats et nac de trouver
la famille qui leur correspond en 2020
ce sont 7 169 amis à quatre pattes qui
ont pu quitter le refuge un mois de
l'adoption qui a donc vocation de
sensibiliser les adoptants mais aussi
d'éviter les abandons en france chaque
année cent mille animaux sont abandonnés
la france qui détient d'ailleurs un ce
triste record et guillaume sanchez est
avec nous par visioconférence bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur général
général de la spa la société protectrice
des animaux
on entendait dans ce reportage au refuge
hors jeu valve cette crainte une crainte
d'une recrudescence des abandons après
le confinement et notamment parce que
peut-être que les personnes parties ont
plus longuement en vacances c'est ce que
vous êtes particulièrement inquiet à la
veille et bien de la deuxième étape du
déconfinement oui on est prononcé sa
présente un motif d'inquiétude c'est
pour ça notamment quand ce n'est très
mobilisés à la fois sur semois de
l'adoption et on laissera également tout
cet été pour essayer de faire la
prévention par rapport à l'abandon pour
la simple et bonne raison que les gens
ont pris des habitudes avec le
confinement ou titre du télétravail ou
kit du mode d'un mode de vie qui était
commun avec l'animal où on peut être
cédé à l'achat plaisir et ont créé un
petit peu tout simplement à retour à
davantage à la normale
yodé confinement alors ça n'a pas été
confirmée à l'été 2020 puis il ya eu
d'abandon en sur les chiens
en revanche on craint un retour des
mauvaises habitudes à l'été 2000 21 mai
parce que le déconfinement et le retour
progressif des personnes au travail ça
peut aussi avoir une conséquence sur les
animaux ils se sont habitués à la
présence de leurs adoptants et ça peut
engendrer peut-être des troubles du
comportement peut être des aboiements
intempestifs par exemple le fait de se
retrouver isolée du jour au lendemain
du coup on imagine que la spa sur cette
période va être particulièrement vif
laon peut-être donner davantage de
conseils c'est le cas d'ailleurs un
commencement de l'adoption
c'est tout à fait en effet l'objectif de
la spa c'est à dire qu'on n'hésite
jamais à la fois à l'égard de nos
adoptant mais également par les vidéos
qu'on utilise combien en oeuvre sur les
réseaux sociaux a donné des conseils de
prise en charge et d'accompagnement des
adoptants de patience aussi c'est pas
parce que l'animal à bois
on va dire les premiers temps lui aussi
il faut qu'ils s'habituent il a été a
été au contact de son maître c'est
pareil pour le chat pendant une période
qui était très longue il faut qu'ils
reprennent aussi un nouveau rythme de
vie avec son maître et que chacun trouve
ses repères à l'intérieur ça veut dire
aussi que le mettre temporairement dans
cette phase de transition doit adapter
peut-être son mode de vie peut être
revenir le midi notamment revenir
promené l'animal quand il le veut
j'entends oui la période de transition
ça c'est primordial de mettre en place
justement une période de transition
oui complètement puisqu'en fait le ça
permettra là où je dirais et aux maîtres
et à l'animal joe de satde de trouver en
fait un nouveau rythme et puis à nouveau
il ses habitudes de vies ont été prises
il je pense que parfois il faut essayer
de regarder le positif c'est à dire
qu'il ya des il ya des instants baladé
un temps convialité des instants de
bonheur avec la famille qu'il faut
essayer de reproduire
peut-être le soir peut-être les
week-ends mais ce qu'on a quand même
constaté aussi c'est que tous les
français en général considèrent que
l'animal est vraiment un membre de la
famille à part entière et donc on n'est
pas inquiet quant aux faits qui lui
feront une place mais en cas de
questions bien sûr il faut faire appel
aux professionnels de la spa justement
le mois de l'adoption a pour objectif
aussi de sensibiliser le public grâce à
ses agents animaliers
c'est un savoir faire on imagine qu est
primordial dans ce processus qui est
important à ce processus de l'adoption
les salariés s'en font vraiment un amour
qu phénoménale et formidable puisque
sont vraiment les acteurs ils ceux qui
reçoivent les abandons qui prennent en
charge des animaux ils les connaissent
ils connaissent leur tempérament est
l'objectif de tout un chacun salariés
comme bénévole à la spa
ces cas d'option soit durable et qu'elle
soit belle on donne des conseils on
confie pas l'animal à n'importe qui oui
et parfois des coups de coeur mais on
connaît l'animal fondamentalement oui
ils connaissent l'animal et ça peut
aussi aider à les diriger vers telle ou
telle adoptant salle expertise justement
du
dudu de l'agent animalier pardon et est
importante aussi pour diriger l'animal
vers la famille la plus parfaite pour
lui on soit primordial tous sont formés
notamment pour c'est pour pouvoir
identifier les caractéristiques de
l'animal
quand ils vous notamment quand ils vont
vous évoquez battait l'incompatibilité
ou le fait que tel animal soit heureux
en forêt c'est parce qu'ils connaissent
l'animal il le fréquente quotidiennement
savent quels sont les besoins de
l'animal est d'ailleurs on n'a pas
hésité à mettre en avant pour la
première fois sur notre campagne
d'adoption
ce sont deux salariés qui finalement
illustre le fait d'avoir un animal qui
arrive chez soi avec un credo qui est
mise en avant aussi pendant ce mois de
l'adoption c'est l'adoption responsable
c'est à dire que c'est un choix réfléchi
quels sont justement les questions que
doivent se poser les futurs adoptants
pour savoir si justement ils peuvent
adopter un animal
déjà il faut déjà s'interroger sur
l'animal c'est d'ailleurs ce que disait
lalalala collègues d'orgeval
c'est est-ce que je suis plutôt chat
chien n'a qu
combien de temps je peux être présent à
la maison pour m'en occuper quels lieux
d'accueil et surtout est-ce que j'ai
bien qu'est-ce que j'en fais pendant les
vacances
combien de vies combien de temps il va
vivre est-ce que j'ai le budget pour me
consacrer et nous notre côté la spa on
va souvent posé des questions sur dans
quelles conditions vous avez prévu de
l'accueillir
vous avez un jeune bébé est ce que c'est
une bonne idée pour le moment est ce
qu'il n'est pas possible plus tôt
peut-être de remettre l'adoption à plus
tard ou l inverse
vous êtes en appartement vous avez
repéré un gros chien est ce que vous
allez disponibles pour pouvoir lui
accorder ce temps nécessaire une aux
questions parfois elles peuvent déranger
mais elles ont vraiment un seul objectif
c'est de faire tout simplement que
l'adoption sur la plus belle possible
est la preuve en est on a très peu de
retours 3 8 % de nos animaux reviennent
au goût l'adoption c'est un chiffre
record record dans le plus bas mais
c'est ce que j'allais vous demandez
c'est une formule qui fonctionne
l'adoption responsable parfaitement
d'autant plus que j'oserais dire nous
notre objectif c'est pas c'est pas de
faire de l'argent donc si la personne
revient parce que ça s'est mal passé que
l'animal les frais d'adoption sont
remboursés l'essentiel c'est cadeau qu
elle soit belle pour l'animal elle soit
belle pour l'adoptant à nouveau c'est
pour ça qu'on donne des conseils et
qu'on lui permet de revenir si jamais il
ya des difficultés mais honnêtement ça
se passe vraiment bien dans 97% des cas
donc on est vraiment très très très
heureux de ces mariages d'amour
une dernière chose vous disiez oui vous
êtes mobilisés en ce moment dans ce mois
de l'adoption la spa qui est mobilisée
toute l'année il y aura une nouvelle
mobilisation aussi à l'été on le sait
une période malheureusement qui
ou au lieu de nombreux abandons il ya
aura une nouvelle nouvelle mobilisation
de l'espère oui on prépare en fait une
campagne qui sera choc très différents
je veux pas vous en dire plus que ce
sera une surprise mais c'est vraiment un
temps rapportant à l'été on constate un
vrai pic deux chats notamment depuis
quelques années qui arrivent vraiment en
nombre suite à des portées de maîtriser
non stérilisés et puis malheureusement
des chiens qui ça c'est ce qu'on craint
avec le déconfinement des gens qui ont
pris le plaisir d'avoir un chien il
était auprès de paul confinement vient
l'été bien les vacances qu'est ce qu'on
en fait en personne peut le prendre veut
pas payer une pension bonbons
l'abandonnent et ça c'est vraiment
vraiment une grande crainte
il faut jamais oublier pour l'animal
c'est vraiment mais c'est un décès une
une souffrance il répète foyer aimant
pour arriver en refuge et ça on aime si
on lui amène tout l'amour du monde
malheureusement c'est quand même une
séparation mais on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en reparler au cours d'une
nouvelle interview sur tv 78 au moment
justement de cette période estivale
toutes les informations sur le mode
l'adoption à sont à retrouver bien sûr
sur le site de la spa qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci guillaume sanchez
d'avoir établi merci pour votre
invitation et je le rappelle directeur
général de la spa la société protectrice
des animaux
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité elle fête
ses dix ans en 2021 l'association
cynophile de police municipale existe
depuis dix ans elle a été fondée à
elancourt par un ex policier municipal
de la ville elle forme les maîtres
chiens à tous les mardis sur un terrain
qui est prêtée par la commune
présentation avec célia de son goût ces
exercices de frappe museler sont
réalisés tous les mardis après midi par
l'association cynophile de police
municipale créée en 2011 par hervé un ex
policier de la police municipale
d'elancourt cette association permet de
former les maîtres chiens elle fait donc
ses 10 ans l'occasion de remettre un
présent à la mairie d'elancourt qui a
oeuvré à son développement
tu es vraiment nous accompagner du début
parce que quand tu auras un terrain où
mettre à disposition un terrain sani
c'est une somme c'est un investissement
les séances d'entraînement s'organise en
trois étapes une première partie
obéissance et sociabilité avec de la
marche au pied puis une deuxième phase
avec des exercices en situation je
m'équipe d'un plastron d'un d'un gilet
renforcé d'un casque pour protéger mon
visage et puis le maître chien on voit
son chien il le chien équipé d'une
misère de frappe d'un colis et d'un
harnais et puis l'on voit le chien en
laisse d'une défense on va dire sur une
agression que que je simule enfin
troisième phase la partie mordante
le chien et divise les ai envoyées à
l'attack des situations que les maîtres
chiens sont amenés à vivre sur la voie
publique
il ya des collègues sur des
interventions qui sont tombés qui ont
pris des coups avec leur chien quand
pouvoir réagir avec le chien qui c'est
qui qui reproche et en relais qu'on
commence place les chansons pour la
majorité des bergers belges malinois
berger allemand ou rottweiler des races
plus prêts destinés au travail frédéric
a intégré la brigade denis d'elancourt
ils en chient en personnel qu'il vient
service de la collectivité
quand j'ai acheté entre police nationale
j'ai toujours voulu allier la passion
alléchant avec mon travail dans la
police
donc c'est pour ça que d'être j'ai pu en
oh mon chien et contre commencé ma
formation tant que maître shah et pour
ceux dont ce nul en dix ans
l'association a formé plus de 50 mètres
chien d'ile-de-france d'eure-et-loir et
d'andré
car faire se rencontrer monde économique
et milieu académique pour permettre aux
entreprises de découvrir l'offre de
formation du territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines et ce afin de recruter leurs
futurs talents et collaborateurs le 27
mai prochain
l'agglomération organise le meet up
école entreprise un rendez vous qui se
veut 100% digitale est des écoles
organismes de formation et l'université
versailles saint quentin seront
présentes avec vous que vous soyez
dirigeants d'entreprise ou drh et les
inscriptions sont ouvertes pour cet
événement toujours à saint quentin en
yvelines une zone de non déchets a été
mise en place par l île de loisirs long
d'une centaine de mètres
elle est située du côté du vélodrome
national encore en phase de test et des
conteneurs sont installés à l'extérieur
de la zone mais l'objectif sur le long
terme et que chaque visiteur repartait
avec ces déchets pour ce faire une
signalétique particulière d'être mises
en place et une brigade et de six
étudiants va se charger de sensibiliser
au tri sélectif à terme ce dispositif
d'un montant de 10000 euros doit faire
de toute l'île de loisirs une zone zéro
déchet et ce d'ici deux ans et coûté
cette interview collectées par miquel et
demi d'euros cette zone de zéro déchet
c'est un c'est une zone test ce qu'on
appelle l'îlot de nature une zone
qui a pour objectif de sensibiliser le
public à la protection environnementale
et au tri des déchets aujourd'hui il est
essentiel que tout le monde soit amené à
faire un effort pour respecter la
planète
nous avons nous comme objectif sur l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
d'en faire un lieu d'excellence en la
matière et nous sommes soutenus par la
région ile de france avant de refermer
ce journal elle fermait ses portes le 31
janvier 2020 à voisins le bretonneux
faute de repreneur après plusieurs
tentatives pour redonner vie au projet
une solution a finalement été à trouver
pour la librairie lettres voisine
le 12 mai dernier le lieu a pu rouvrir
dans d'autres locaux loués par la ville
elle les précisions de bixente mayence
insisté ban un nouveau chapitre pour la
librairie lettres voisine de
voisins-le-bretonneux fermé depuis
janvier 2020 faute de repreneur une
solution a été trouvée pour une
réouverture dans de nouveaux locaux
loués par la mairie ça fait un bout de
temps que l'être voisines avaient fermé
et c'est toujours très triste une
librairie qui ferment et donc je suis là
aujourd'hui je juste pas pour acheter
des livres aujourd'hui mais en tous les
cas pour vérifier qu'elle est bien
ouvert qu'on attendait depuis plusieurs
mois on ne savait pas en fait ce que ce
que c'était devenu on a été très
attristée par par massa sa fermeture et
donc oreilles c'est une super nouvelle
mille livres neufs et plus de 2000
livres d'occasion sont déjà à
disposition une réouverture poussé par
christine sauvage libraire emblématique
de la ville avec trente années
d'ancienneté qui a soutenu la relance du
projet
le fait de recréer quelque chose toutes
façons c'est une bonne chose c'est
surtout de voir que un projet qui était
peut-être par moments on voyait ne pas
se réaliser de voir se réaliser c'est
quand même
bon grands bénéfices et du coup la
retraite se passe très bien
une solution qui reste précaire
christine sauvage et son binôme françois
vernon également sorti de la retraite
assure tas de l'ouverture en attendant
de trouver un libraire pour reprendre le
poste il a fallu reprendre un petit peu
les choses mois de janvier imaginez une
autre construction à une autre
organisation
dans quelque temps il faudra à nouveau
trouvé vraiment un professionnel qui
reprennent l'ensemble est qui qui se
relance à partir de ce que nous avons
rouvert aujourd'hui la mairie louant les
locaux pour un peu plus de deux ans il
s'agira également et avant l'expiration
du bail de trouver un futur espace pour
les lettres voisine et dans un instant
sur tv 60,18 retrouver une nouvelle
édition du cetud sport et s'est
présentée par vous ou michele me d'euros
bonsoir soir est à la tête bien sûr de
cette émission à une émission qui
intervient deux jours avant la levée
progressive des restrictions de la
pratique sportive quel est le programme
du jour
alors le programme alors est ce que vous
connaissez françois mendy rigoriste pas
du tout pas du tout alors c'est un
joueur qui a joué pendant une dizaine
d'années à trappes à l'étoile sportive
de trappes et qui vient de signer son
premier contrat professionnel avec le
club de châteauroux il jouera en
national l'année prochaine on l'aura
avec nous dans cette émission dans ce
set 8 sport on parlera également basket
coup de projecteur aujourd'hui sur mike
mot congo le sportif originaire de
république centrafricaine joue
aujourd'hui dans le club de trappes peut
également vous le connaissez oui il y
participe également à l'émission si on
parlait sport il a joué à chalon à
monaco en espagne il est aujourd'hui
attrape un reportage anti portrait sur
lui dans cette émission on parlera
également baseball les cougars de
montier bretons ne débuteront finalement
leur saison à la mi juin en penser qu'il
n'ya les parloirs de saison pour les
cougars de nancy bretonneux et
finalement en baseball
ils pourront jouer mi juin contre or en
début de saison et on espère qu'ils
iront le plus haut possible bien sûr
merci michael un programme riche qu'on
retrouve à partir de 18h30 sur tv 78 au
menu donc du 7-8 sport voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]